- [Sal] Esther, I'm in so much trouble!
- [Esther] What happened, Sal?
- [Sal] Ben Eater, the number
eater, ate all my numbers
on my perfect number grid.
- [Ben] Hahahaha! Those
were some good numbers!
(chewing)
I better get out of here
before I get into some trouble!
- [Sal] Ben!
Esther, what do I do?
- [Esther] It's okay, Sal.
We can work together to
find the missing numbers.
Actually, I think our friends who are
watching the video can help us with it.
So, friend, go ahead and pause the video
and see if you can figure
out the missing numbers.
- [Sal] Okay, I'm assuming our friends
have given a go at it.
So how would you think about this, Esther?
- [Esther] Let's see, hmm.
Well, maybe I can use the
numbers that are before
the missing number to
help us figure this out.
So let's see, if we go from
4, 5, 6, 7!
- [Sal] That makes sense.
What about this one?
- [Esther] Hmm.
Let's see, let's see if we
can figure out what would
come after the number 13.
- [Sal] Maybe we should get our friends
to think about it first.
- [Esther] Good idea.
- [Sal] So I'm assuming they tried.
So how do you think about it?
What number comes after 13?
- [Esther] Let's see, 13, 14!
- [Sal] And that works out, because then
14 is the number that comes before 15.
- [Esther] Exactly.
- [Sal] I see.
Now look at this, this
is all the way out here.
How are you going to figure
this one out, Esther?
- [Esther] Hmm, let's see.
Maybe I can look at the numbers that come
after the missing number.
So if we have 37 and 38 and 39,
I think 36 comes before 37!
- [Sal] Oh, that makes a lot of sense.
And what about this one
that's right below it?
- [Esther] Okay, let's see,
I think I'm gonna count
in a different way.
I'm gonna go from the top to the bottom.
- [Sal] Wow, how are you going to do that?
- [Esther] Let's see, I'll
start with number 6, and I'll
go down to 16, go down to 26,
go down to 36.
- [Sal] I think I see a pattern here.
All of these numbers have a 6.
- [Esther] Exactly. So I think if we're
in the missing number, that's gonna be 46.
- [Sal] Oh, I see, that makes sense.
Cos here this was, we're in 26, then 36,
here we're in the 40s.
So it's going to be 46.
- [Esther] Exactly!
- [Sal] That's really cool.
Now what about these three down here?
Maybe our friends can pause first and see
if they can figure it out.
- [Esther] Sounds good!
- [Sal] Okay, how would
I tackle this, Esther?
- [Esther] Let's see. Well,
there are three missing numbers
all in a row, so let's look at
the numbers before and after.
So we have 81, 82, 83, 84!
- [Sal] Oh, that makes
sense cos we're in the 80s.
And so just like we have 1, 2, 3, 4,
now it's 81, 82, 83, 84.
- [Esther] Exactly.
And I know the number
that is next to 84 is 85.
- [Sal] And we know that
because 5 comes after 4,
so 85 comes after 84.
- [Esther] Bingo!
- [Sal] Wow. And this would be...
- [Both] 86!
- [Sal] Very exciting.
- [Esther] Very fun.
("Charge")
- [Sal] Oh no, it's Ben
Eater the number eater again!
- [Ben] Oh, more numbers to munch on!
I'm getting hungry!